see as you seem to enjoy my videos on
underappreciated anime we here once
again to bring you some recommendations
that you might have missed out on yes
that's right it's time for volume 3 of
underappreciated anime whether it be due
to the strength of the season or just as
genre being niche some anime inevitably
get overshadowed that's what this
channel is here for and today I'll be
helping you go through another ten
titles that you might have just
overlooked a bit when they came out so
buckle up and here we go with another 10
titles that in my opinion need just a
little bit more love Drifters comes in
at number 10 giving us a glimpse of a
story with historical context historical
figures yanked from their own timelines
are fought into a dimension where they
wage war against one another doesn't
that sound like fate so yeah these
heroes called drifters comprised of some
familiar figures like Oda Nobunaga and
Shimazu our protagonist they take the
battle against ends another group of
historical figures strangely enough
including some historically good people
like the Japanese favourite Jean d'Arc
it's time for a gritty edgy battle royal
like you've never seen before
fans would probably recognize got the
Hirano of Helsing Fame and you can
clearly see the influence in the
presentation of this anime it's edgy
it's dark and it has that cool stylish
Flair that we've come to know from the
story of Alucard
and his allies if you're up for some
edgy historical fights make sure to give
this 2016 Show a spin
next we have Vic cross I think that a
lot of us have grown up around card game
anime for those on the wrong side of the
twenties like I am you might have
remembered your elementary years with
yu-gi-oh on the other hand the younger
ones might associate card game anime
with bushy road heat card fight Vanguard
however in the midst of those titles in
the genre that doubles as lengthy
commercials for toys is Vic Ross I'd
like to talk about the series as a whole
instead of just selector infected Vic
Ross the first season because the
premise more or less remains similar for
each season young girls playing a card
game where winning allows them to have a
wish granted however a dark twist awaits
at the end of each road to glory not
only do the characters have their wishes
overturned and reversed if they lose
often enough and even darker fate lies
at the end of their journey if it
reminds you of something congratulations
I've just introduced you to Madoka with
trading cards the turn and the overall
feel of the anime varies between seasons
but they all follow one generally
streamlined narrative I also like how
each series follows a new protagonist
who still gets to interact with familiar
faces from the previous seasons giving
the whole thing a sense of continuity
licensing and possibly trust issues
between companies means that the actual
card game would likely never see an
English release which off the bat hurts
the popularity of the series nonetheless
I think that the series is worth a look
and I found myself really enjoying how
the story developed through its four
connected seasons
moving on past the darkness of girls
doing things for the sake of wishes how
about a literature inspired romantic
comedy boarding school Juliet is at
number eight we've had countless
literary inspired titles over the course
of anime history but this is one title
that caught my eye in particular towards
the end of 2018 set in a more modern
world boarding school Juliet takes a
more relatable approach in telling the
story of Romeo and Juliet's forbidden
love this time the setting takes place
in Dalia Academy the melting pot for two
countries embroiled in a bitter feud the
black doggies and the white cats have
themselves a long-standing feud led by
their leaders Romeo inuzuka and Juliet
Persia the thing is the two leaders are
actually really really in love with each
other with the feud between the houses
that's an all-time high the couple just
has to come to terms with the fact that
they might be forced to keep their
relationship a secret forever with
prying eyes from friends and rivals
alike how much longer can they keep this
act up I got drawn into the series due
to the cute character designs and the
premise that somehow reminded me of
Nyssa coy at first and I'd say that the
series needs a lot more love than it
actually got the scenarios were fun and
enjoyable and I liked the development of
the side characters in particular the
author has done a really great job of
creating some lovable characters and a
lot of funny incidents to put them in
making this a really fun watch if you're
looking to unwind with some rom-coms
airing in a season with waifu wars
generator Nisekoi supernatural fantasy
noragami ever beloved space dandy and me
material pupa there's a cute little show
about teenage drama with a dash of
Japanese spiritualism yes I'm not
surprised that NRI kon Kon was one of
the underrated shows in that particular
season given the strength of the season
I believe that this title is actually at
its proper place in that seasons
popularity charts however that doesn't
change the fact that I think this is one
heartwarming series that more people
should watch and appreciate the story
premise is simple enough middle school
girl finds herself hopelessly in love
cries about her inability to confess it
to shrine and the shrines goddess grants
her the power to transform well turns
out being in love isn't as easy as being
able to pretend to be someone else in
order to make your confession especially
if you've gotten yourself involved in
the affairs of gods and spirits in the
process
Inari Khan Khan offers what a standard
anime of this genre typically gives cute
heartwarming moments some magic
sprinkled in and a fun and adorable cast
of characters despite its shorter than
usual 10 episode run the show manages to
hit its mark personally I prefer the
more action Ishaan Rah's but even I was
charmed by this show and I think that
you should give it a shot too
so tell us okay go
you know with the wake of the attack on
Titan phenomenon in 2013 those who
prepare anime can't help but green light
those dystopian humanity vs. monster
shows in order to ride the wave so we
got stuff like syrup of the end or
carbon Airy of the iron fortress or
black bullet among these I think that
the one that went under the radar the
most was gordita now I honestly think
this show needed more love sure is Noah
near the masterpiece that it was trying
to ride the momentum front but so are
the other three shows that I mentioned I
think that as a game adaptation gordita
is fine it goes with a tried and true
story of humanity fighting for survival
against monsters with their special
equipment meant to combat those threats
the CG art might be the breaking point
for a lot of fans during its time but I
never felt that the art completely
hampered my enjoyment of seeing amazing
intense fights in the series it's an
acquired taste but after having seen
stuff like our Jian and Knights of
Cydonia I think that I stopped letting
our affect my enjoyment unless of course
it's something as horrible as re fear at
those monsters now that was something
else
I can see that God Eater started off
pretty dull but after a few episodes I
found myself enthralled with the
characters fight for survival if you're
up for some popcorn anime before the
next season of attack on Titan you
should definitely go for this show
remember the good old days when we got a
lot of visual novel adaptations the
genre slowed down drastically this past
decade but every once in a while we
still get some surprisingly great ones
one such title is 2016 so no kanata no
for rhythm shortened as O'Connor set in
a futuristic world where man has finally
conquered the skies people go around
flying in grav shoes footwear that allow
people to defy gravity and fly so people
came up with flying circus a sport that
fully utilizes such wonders of
technology in simple terms Arcana is a
Sports anime centered on bright and
optimistic
Oscar Korra Sheena and her friends at
the FC club at school it's more or less
your standard sports title so you kind
of know what to expect in addition to
the character designs that drew me into
the series our first what I found in our
kana is a surprisingly deep story for my
expectations that let me empathize with
the characters and the challenges they
face our Ghana
really does a good job at showing the
journey from newbie into someone
becoming good at the sport as well as
some moments that showcase the
satisfaction of winning and the heart
breaks into feet whatever your saves on
this I believe that our Ghana is one of
the underrated gems from the past few
years
[Music]
Kosciuszko
hatsune chica
our fourth spot is what I think is an
even better sports anime this time it's
a manga adaptation that debut just
recently in late 2018 run with the wind
tells the story of God guru who starts
this tale on quite the wrong side of the
law narrowly evading consequence for
shoplifting he runs into [ __ ] who
invites him to live with him in a
run-down apartment
given that Garg arrow isn't in the best
place financially he accepts the
invitation and finds himself at the
headquarters of the conse University
track club it's there that [ __ ] reveals
his goal he wants to win it all at the
biggest university marathon relay race
in Japan problem is the rest of the dorm
mates and novice runners and they're not
even interested
somehow the premise might remind you of
our hero no sora another sports anime
that i think needs a bit more love -
when i first took a look at it a lot of
people have praised run with the wind
but i just think that the genre is not
doing so hot right now in terms of
popularity
except for maybe high q-- it doesn't
help that it came out alongside headline
grabber goblin slayer bunny girl sent by
zombie land saga and the new seasons of
sao as well as index i personally give
the recommendation to watch run with the
wind one of the most underrated shows of
that particular season in our third
place is a movie when Marnie was there
takes the third spot
being the only anime film on this
edition of this list anime films have
been gaining ground the past couple of
years in no large part thanks to the
masterpieces of filmmakers let Shinkai
as well as the sudden urge in releasing
said films outside of japan however lost
in the shuffle of the flood of emotional
and artistic anime films is the dramatic
tale based on the classic children's
novel when Marnie was there basically
tells the story of our protagonist Anna
whose health conditions forced her into
living in Sapporo there she finds an
abandoned mansion and starts a series of
encounters with the girl that she sees
in her dreams as the story goes on the
mystery surrounding the girl from Anna's
dreams and her relation to the rest of
Anna's family begins to unravel in a
rollercoaster of emotions given the
pedigree oh she blew in the anime
movie markets I'm not surprised that
when Marnie was there ended up being
underappreciated it didn't live up to
films like spirited away or toward or oh
when it comes to capturing the hearts of
many but I still think that you should
really give this film a shot the classic
Ghibli film traits of amazing artwork
and fantastic storytelling are there and
I think that this is one of the films
that really made me emotional in the way
it delivered its drama it also has a lot
of themes that can hit close to home
especially for those having troubles
with family acceptance and abandonment
it's a tearjerker film that really
deserves a bit more popularity than what
it currently has Mononoke is the
adaptation of a Japanese horror
anthology centered on the medicine
cellar and his journey across Japan
defeating evil spirits along the way
Mononoke for me gives itself a unique
edge over the other evil spirits Lange
shows by not just being about
superpowers and exciting action for the
medicine cellar to defeat an evil spirit
he has to get to know it first this
includes getting information such as its
form origin and motive this opens up a
lot of possibilities as some of the
spirits tend to be quite the Troublesome
ones to analyze I think that there are
people who would love this style in
comparison to the more action-packed
style of shows in this genre like bleach
and Demon Slayer for just a slight
change of pace the show also sets itself
apart from its contemporaries with its
eye-catching art style it might take a
while to get used to scenes and
character designs reminiscent of ancient
Japanese art but I think that the art
style is exactly part of the show's
charm Mononoke is a surprisingly
intricate and deep look at the
supernatural genre and I definitely
consider it not only underappreciated
but one of the best horror anime out
there period
now where do I start with Astra lost in
space I admit that it's a show that I
didn't have the strong impression of at
first but the way the story develop just
made me a believer I'm sure that the
same opinion is the general opinion of
the anime community and it's the biggest
reason why for me the three episode rule
isn't completely a good way of looking
at things three episodes just isn't
enough for one to appreciate the amazing
ride Astra lost in space ended up being
what started out being an okay premise
of friends being lost in space ended
being one of the best space dramas I've
seen for such a long time Astra lost in
space really excels as showing the
struggles in the fight to overcome outer
space in order to battle their way back
home ironic that I use the word battle
because the series doesn't really have a
lot of that instead the dialogue and the
presentation do the heavy lifting and
helping you empathize with the
characters who are really well developed
by the way you don't see this much care
put in making characters these days and
it truly makes Astra lost in space as
standout in the saturation of characters
in modern anime the show can admittedly
be a drag at first which I think caused
it to be underappreciated still I really
recommend this because it turned out to
be one of the best surprises in the
season I go with the consensus of this
show being one that eventually grew out
to be among the top shows in the whole
of 2019 how's that for the third volume
of our underrated anime if you've seen
these shows make sure to let your
friends in the comments section know do
you think that they deserve more
popularity than what they have why or
why not
don't forget to leave a like if you
enjoyed the video if we get 15,000 likes
again I will consider making another
volume don't forget to subscribe if you
want to see more content like this the
bell buttons also there so you can be
the first in line the next time I upload
a new video till we meet again
[Music]